and then i turned a corner on that and
then
right soon after that when what david
and showalter were doing wet hot
and i did american summer it went out
american summer and i went and shot that
with them and i was with that group
again
as well as like paul and amy and
brad and
uh uh uh everybody cooper cooper
everybody who worked on that and
i was like oh
this can exist
there are other people outside of the
state that are good kind positive
creative awesome people
i don't need to
suffer through working with people who
are not particularly kind
i can just work with people i like
and then
uh you know that
that shift and also um
kind of getting my
power back uh you know kind of
dovetailed into each other and since
then i guess i've had a
uh
you know
going with your observation i've been
more confident with how i approach uh
this business
and life
yeah i know that that makes sense that's
a fantastic answer
i just feel like
there's times in my life where i feel
like i've lost it like i've lost that
confidence and you said something really
important and you said something
you know you have the tools
is it that for a while there you forget
about the tools that you have and you're
just
like almost like looking at your ugly
self and and thinking i can't do this
but then realizing wait a minute i can
do this i've done this before
well i mean i can only speak for you
know through
about my personal experiences of how it
happened and when i was doing the state
it was like being in a band and you know
you as you were together longer you sort
of you sort of have uh you've dug
a hole for yourself or you've you've
created a certain niche
part of the group or like a a section of
a
you've created
your personality within the group and
there was
at a certain point there's no
reversing that you can adjust but
there's no reversing it but i was who i
was in that group and i had
and i
for better for worse that's who i was
when i left that group
and and by the way
the state was on a show
that what you guys created in college
you and david wayne and a bunch of other
guys yeah show waltz when he's and it
aired on mtv from 93 to 95 and it was
this comic troupe and you did all these
skits and things for those yeah mtv and
then right we
not broke up we just stopped making
money so everybody had to go off and do
their own thing
you